YOU WILL JOIN US THEN.
HAVE A GREAT EVENING,
SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
TONIGHT, MORE POSITIVE
STATISTICS FOR THIS COUNTRY’S
FIGHT AGAINST COVA 19 PLUS MORE
BOLD ACTION FROM THE
PRESIDENT THIS TIME AGAINST THE
CHINA CENTRIC WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
WE HAVE AN UPDATE AND WILL BREAK
DOWN THE DETAILS FOR YOU.
ALSO MIKE POMPEO FASCINATING
INFORMATION THAT THEY HAVE
RELEASED FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
ALSO WITH JUST 203 DAYS UNTIL
ELECTION DAY AND YOU THE PEOPLE
ARE THE ULTIMATE JURY,
QUID PRO QUO JOE EVER CONFUSED
ONE FINALLY GOT THE ENDORSEMENTS
HE HAS ANXIOUSLY BEEN WAITING
FOR.
AFTER EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE DROPPED OUT AND EVEN
AFTER BERNIE SANDERS FINALLY
ANNOUNCED THE SUPPORT OF THE
PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE, FINALLY WE
HEAR FROM HIM.
PRESIDENT OBAMA STEPPED UP TODAY
AND FINALLY MANAGED TO RELEASE
AN INTERNET VIDEO KIND OF WEEK
OFFERING SUPPORT FOR HIS FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT.
THE QUESTION FOR ME IS WHY THIS
WAY?
WHY IN THE MIDDLE OF A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND PANDEMIC?
LAST MONDAY AND, DID HE FINALLY
DECIDED TO ENDORSE QUID PRO QUO
JOE?
MAYBE HE DIDN’T WANT ANYONE TO
HEAR IT.
AFTER ALL, IF ANYONE KNOWS THAT
JOE DOESN’T HAVE A FASTBALL OR
SLOW PITCH, IT HAS TO BE OBAMA.
DURING HIS GLOWING ENDORSEMENT,
HE CALLED BITE IN THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE CANDIDATE IN
HISTORY.
AND HE CAN’T GET FOX NEWS OUT OF
HIS HEAD.
HE CAN’T.
WE LIVE IN HIS MIND.
I LIVE IN HIS MIND.
I DON’T KNOW WHY, BUT TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I’M SO PROUD TO ENDORSE
JOE BIDEN FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
CHOOSING JOE TO BE MY
VICE PRESIDENT WAS ONE OF THE
BEST DECISIONS I EVER MADE.
JOE ALREADY HAS WHAT IS THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE PLATFORM OF ANY
MAJOR PARTY NOMINEE IN HISTORY.
OUR COUNTRY’S FUTURE HANGS ON
THIS ELECTION.
AND IT WON’T BE EASY.
THE OTHER SIDE HAS A MASSIVE
WAR CHEST.
THE OTHER SIDE HAS A PROPAGANDA
NETWORK WITH LITTLE REGARD FOR
THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: HE IS NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE REAL PROPAGANDA
NETWORKS.
WE’VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR
MONTHS, THERE ARE NO MORE
MODERATES INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE’S ACKNOWLEDGING IT.
EXTREME, SOCIALIST, DEMOCRATS
FULLY ADOPTING THE MADNESS OF
PRENEW DEAL POLICIES FROM THE
RADICAL LEFT.
NOW WE HAVE THE EVER CONFUSED
JOE BIDEN AS THE LEADER OF THIS
EXTREME SOCIALIST PARTY RUNNING
ON A PLATFORM THAT EVEN
BOLSHEVIK BURNING IS PROUD OF.
AND IN THE MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC, HE CAN’T STOP
ATTACKING FOX NEWS AFTER ALL
THESE YEARS, WE ARE ALIVE AND
WELL IN HIS MIND AND FOR SOME
REASON, NEVER LIKED ME.
JUST A QUICK REMINDER IN HISTORY
LESSON.
>> IN 2012, LATINOS VOTED IN
RECORD NUMBERS.
THE NEXT DAY, EVEN SEAN HANNITY
CHANGED HIS MIND AND DECIDED
IMMIGRATION REFORM WAS A GOOD
IDEA.
>> RUDY GIULIANI SAID HE IS WHAT
YOU CALL THE LEADER.
THEY KEEP TALKING ABOUT HIS BARE
CHEST.
WHICH IS KIND OF WEIRD WITH
RESPECT TO SEAN HANNITY.
I DIDN’T KNOW.
HIS OPINION OF ME DOES NOT SEEM
TO BE VERY HIGH.
BUT I’M ALWAYS GOOD FOR A BEER.
I WILL PUT HIM UP AGAINST
SEAN HANNITY.
HE WILL TEAR HIM UP.
>> Sean: I’M SURE I’LL HAVE TO
PAY FOR THE BEER.
THE THING IS, HE WAS MORE
ENERGETIC IN THOSE VIDEOS THEN
HE WAS IN THIS ONLINE
ENDORSEMENT THING TODAY.
LIKE HIS DEVOUT FOLLOWERS IN THE
MEDIA MOB, IT’S LIKE WE LIVE IN
HIS HEAD, THIS NETWORK.
WE LIVE AND A LOT OF PEOPLE’S
HEAD.
WE LIVE IN FAKENESS CNN’S HEAD
BECAUSE WE ARE THE ONES AND WE
WILL THAT WHOEVER IS RUNNING AND
LOOKS LIKE EVER CONFUSED
QUID PRO QUO SUPER THURSDAY, WE
ARE THE ONLY ONES THAT EXPOSED.
WE DID A DEEP DIVE INTO THE
RADICAL HATE PREACHER.
WE WERE RIGHT ABOUT REVEREND
WRIGHT, WERE THE ONES THAT
EXPOSED HIS TIES WITH THE
WEATHER UNDERGROUND, WE WERE THE
ONES THAT EXPOSED AS LIES ABOUT
OBAMACARE, MILLIONS OF YOU ARE
ALL PAYING 200% MORE.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE THE ONLY
ONES THAT WAS THAT THE EVER
CONFUSED QUID PRO QUO JOE.
WE WILL HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE HORRIFIC OBAMA-BIDEN RECORD.
EIGHT YEARS, 13 MILLION MORE
AMERICANS.
DO THEY HATE MORE?
LIMITS LABOR PARTICIPATION RATE
SINCE THE 70s, I CUMULATE IN
MORE DEPTH THAN ANY OTHER
ADMINISTRATION BEFORE THEM
COMBINED AND LOWEST
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE IN 50 YEARS,
WORST RECOVERY SINCE THE 40s
AND FOR THE NEXT 200 PLUS DAYS,
WE WILL CONTINUE TO FALL OUT.
AT THE DEMOCRATIC RADICAL
SOCIALIST PARTY, PROPAGANDA ARM
WHICH IS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
MOB AND INCLUDING QUID PRO QUO
JOE IS ABUSE OF POWER.
AND YES, HIS ZERO EXPERIENCE ON
HUNTER THAT GOT FILTHY RICH WITH
NO EXPERIENCE.
YOU THINK THAT FAKE NEWS CNN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WASHINGTON POST," DO YOU THINK
THEY’LL EVER LET JOE BIDEN KNOW
THEY PROTECTED HIM?
THEY CARED ABOUT OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE BUT NOT HILLARY’S
EMAILS.
THEY CARED ABOUT RUSSIAN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE BUT NOT
HILLARY’S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DIRTY DOSSIER USED TO SPY ON A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE DEEP INTO
HIS PRESIDENCY.
WE’RE GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT.
THEIR SOLE MISSION, BEAT
DONALD TRUMP, SLANDER
DONALD TRUMP.
THE SAME PEOPLE EVEN IN THE
MIDDLE OF A NATIONAL CRISIS AND
PANDEMIC, HEALTH EMERGENCY, THE
MOB IN THE MEDIA ADDICTIVELY
CARES ABOUT ONE THING, WHAT THEY
CARED ABOUT SINCE DONALD TRUMP
AND MILANI A TERM CAME DOWN THAT
ESCALATOR IN TRUMP TOWER.
IS SLANDERING.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH HIM FOR
CURING CANCER.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN YEARS, WE
HAVE A PRESIDENT NOT AFRAID TO
FIGHT BACK AND HE DOES IT WITH
POWER AND GUSTO AND ENERGY.
JOE COULD USE SOME ENERGY, TAKE
A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE A FEW CLIPS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO PUT UP, I THINK
YOU’LL FIND IT INTERESTING.
WE COULD GIVE YOU HUNDREDS OF
CLIPS JUST LIKE THAT.
WE HAVE THEM.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, IT’S VERY
SAD WHEN PEOPLE RIGHT FALSE
STORIES.
WE DID ALL OF THIS WORK, BUT
WHEN YOU READ THE PHONY STORIES,
NOBODY ACKNOWLEDGES THIS, AND IT
DOESN’T HAVE TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED
FROM MY STANDPOINT, BUT IT DOES
HAVE TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED FROM THE
GREAT WORK THAT THESE DOCTORS,
NURSES, THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS TEAM, ALL THESE PEOPLE
HAVE DONE THIS INCREDIBLE JOB.
>> Sean: 90% OF THIS COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN AMAZING.
CORPORATIONS, PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES THAT WE ARE TRAINED TO
HATE.
WALMART, ALL OF THESE COMPANIES
ALL HANDS ON DECK.
THE NURSES, THE DOCTORS, THE
RESEARCHERS, THE SCIENTISTS.
WE HAVE SEEN THE ABSOLUTE BEST
OF AMERICA DURING A REALLY
DIFFICULT TIME.
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS.
THE PREDICTABLE PEOPLE, THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA, TRIM CAN DO
NOTHING RIGHT.
THEY CAN’T INTELLECTUALLY BE
HONEST ENOUGH TO SAY IN
RETROSPECT, THAT XENOPHOBIC
FEARMONGERING TRAVEL BAN AND
QUARANTINE FIRST TIME IN 50
YEARS AND SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL BAN,
HOW MANY AMERICANS DIDN’T
CONTRACT THAT DISEASE?
HOW MANY AMERICANS EXPONENTIALLY
DIDN’T DIE?
HOW MUCH WORSE WITH THIS BE?
THAT’S THE MOB IN THE MEDIA.
THAT IS A DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY’RE WORKING ON AN
INVESTIGATION?
ANOTHER SHOW IN THE MIDDLE OF A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
AND HE WANTS THE MEDIA TO STOP
COVERING IN THE MIDDLE OF A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY NEWS AND
INFORMATION COMING FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
PRETTY SICK, BUT PREDICTABLE FOR
THEM.
BY THE WAY, EVERYTHING THEY’RE
SAYING IS THROUGH THE 2020
PRISM.
FOR THEM, IT’S ABOUT 203 DAYS,
ALL POLITICS.
THEIR RAGE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
IS SO EXTREME, SO HATEFUL, SO
PSYCHOTIC I’VE BEEN SAYING FOR
THREE YEARS, THEY ARE HURTING
OUR COUNTRY.
THEY DON’T CARE.
NOT THE TRAVEL BAN, NOT THE
QUARANTINES, THEY WON’T GIVE
THIS PRESIDENT -- THIS IS THE
GREATEST MEDICAL MOBILIZATION IN
THE HISTORY OF MANKIND.
WE ROSE TO THE OCCASION BECAUSE
OF THE GREATNESS, THE GOODNESS
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE PRESIDENT, THE
VICE PRESIDENT, THEIR TASK FORCE
AND OTHERS TOO.
FIVE GOVERNORS DID WELL HERE.
NOW I’VE SAID IT MANY, MANY
TIMES, THE MEDIA IN AMERICA IS A